I was kind of imprecise hello and
welcome yeah this is the Monday Night
Live show yeah I've done those yeah a
lot over the years but this is a new
place going to play a bit on the chest
I'm going to join the how it is super
blitz arena so I'm kicking off oops with
the Super blitz arena and then later
play some challenges so let's see what
c4 chess can do I went one year for
mixing mixing it up and I made the same
friggin mistake yeah I keep doing that
I forget to to build this to get the
chat window on where is that
let's do how about I keep forgetting
this no I've got a chat window huh so
yeah let's play I should really do that
before the scene when I keep forgetting
that so I've got a chat window to read
messages um yeah I've got a bit should
be 5 Sicilian yeah
this is looking like you know pass a lot
let's see each castles this is how you
can play it I think yeah widest quite
okay in this position yeah this is
possible but I don't think it works
not entirely
I'm stopping stopping stuff yonder under
the back rank and he does not really
have something here against my knight
I'm going Queen d2 my next
so let's do this and kick this back I'm
not sure about how to play this 55 yeah
keeping it a bit closed it's probably
not a bad idea
and then consolidate okay so I've got
the got this sorted interesting
interesting
the bishop will come to b6 this is
definitely not bad oh okay
interesting idea all night a4 may be
coming oh I think I'm still okay because
the bishop on yeah I have before here
huh the bishop on b7 is so bad yeah it
looks good but I have to still be
technically precise and if I tick on a5
okay rook c8 I'll see ya know to all of
you in the chat couple of regulars there
thanks for joining in so anyway this is
not so easy it's actually not so easy
the bishop on d4 will be very strong
very annoying this player on the dark
squares
yeah I just want to keep his pieces out
and then see how I can possibly win this
Bishop to age three maybe maybe he can
play the Bishop to c8 that would be
quite annoying
yeah Bishop c3 but this is not helping
him so much and now this for Queen to c7
was my idea I have 37 seconds that is
cause for concern to say the least
Queen c7 oops
Queen Queen c7 he had the bishop
mustachio
okay okay for some nothing I could do
I'm winning the bishop from winning the
rook okay yeah the Queen stack was I
guess basically correct okay so of the
super blitz arena some good players here
like scope see him yeah I already get
challenges but I'm going to play that
tournament first okay I look at paired
what's going on here spot Winiarski yeah
I did not manage to post a video on my
my youtube channel to get maybe some
more people on the stream but it's um
something I need to do I simply couldn't
manage today oh he gives me this so was
it surprising spot Winiarski gives me
this trade okay
probably will just take know huh
no I did not really get rest before the
stream I was working but it's ok it
still would still be still be fine I'm
going here going here and maybe Bishop
g4 yeah a full workday yesterday
now everything is everything's fine
it's been it's been it's been years
since I was working in the bank
it's been yes I left close to four years
it is yeah that I have then I lost left
my office job and yes they actually did
something with my internet this morning
this is going to be interesting to watch
even if it helped what they basically
did is they they changed my the cable
connection so they just gave me a
different cable but the cable that I had
to connect like the wall socket
to my to my router was SS that as the
tech persons had the worst cable ever
maybe that actually helps and we'll see
okay so here this is a very close
position but I'm going to try to do
something here on on the kingside the
queenside is closed and I tried to open
here the F file and so on yeah he's got
a g4 but I have 97 he cannot hope maybe
b6 is actually an interesting move if I
hope he doesn't spot that
huh I have g4 here and then look f2 yeah
that's a good idea
let's do it fiber cable I don't know
fiber hmm
no I mean I've got I've got like the
cable internet yeah from the cable TV
let's say the same provider that the
test that has the TV but um I think
fiber something that is that is even
quicker right now we don't have that
okay well here I can take and go e4 and
then get the King to e5 that looks that
looks not so easy b6
where do I go to f6 hmm
yeah nights are more flexible here in
this position but I don't don't see how
can I can make any headway I can try to
go to g5 but
still not not going to need too much
might so be drawn
King III King F two words from his
children king of what
he gives me that whole okay that sucks
that sucks so bad that I get disposition
I now belong to the Queen there was a
great start I don't know I don't know
what I'd have him how that happened ah
it was pretty bad yeah dial-up internet
yeah it's I when I played the first a
year playing chess on the ISS see that
was 1997 playing on the ICC it was still
dial-up that I had okay so it doesn't
really it's not a it's not the end of
the world that loss was a bit bit silly
but the tournament situation is sill
okay
okay d4 that's a good old folk yeah so
I'm winning a piece 10 10 gigabyte 10
gigabit cab it's symmetrical Wow
yeah I don't know I think oopsy gives me
the Queen as well what we are doing my
day job I'm teaching chess mostly I'm
mostly teaching I do some streaming
which is not really qualifying for a job
maybe but most of it is teaching and I
do be a chess content like videos and
and opening books publications doing
stuff really chess at the moment so baha
going for other Scandinavian know this
looks wacky hey I get a good development
here okay I think I need to open this
young
[Music]
yeah of course game revenues I would do
of course of the 45 45 Nick okay
I'd try something interesting here
offering him a queen trade and my idea
is to get Knight to be five and quickly
my development is a lot better and I
wanted to open this up so I can take us
and now here he's got Knight a six
dollar and this is keeping things
somewhat under control yeah it still has
some issues there with the knight here
is annoying I'm always looking at this
and I have this on so it's not so easy
for him okay
don't think okay rook d7 now is an
option but he's got Bishop f6 hey I
should do a line of merchandise to
compete with the chess brass that's a
funny idea Oh gives me this pawn I'm
taking this yeah it shakes just
explained muck yeah I know
this is there are some things that I
really would like shiny head on the
shirt yes yeah I get your point okay I
should cover bb2 and
now let's see how do you win this kingly
3b3 push flag back back in black No
okay so let's do this the picture of me
on the screen after the stream ends
you mean the picture that I have on the
twitch channel yes I intend to I intend
to do streams yes and I mean I'm not
going to do playing streams only I'm
also going to do some instructional
streams at the time not today but in
general I want to do that but I want to
do I want to use the twitch platform
simply because I think it's more
interactive yeah the picture that I have
on the on the channel is some it's
actually a usual professional
photography of mine that the
photographer here made and I just
tweaked it a little bit using using an
app that was fairly easy to do actually
I was surprised how easy it was and I
think it looks really ok for me being a
complete amateur in that regard okay 93
probably okay I get C 6-under on the
road and I think those pawns are too
quick
let's kill 96 yeah
now that picture there then have there
you have to have to actually see that it
is a real chess positional it's it's out
of my c4 repertoire yeah so it's it's
not a random chess position ok so over
the two nights and with d4 this this
should lead to a really nice position
for me
yeah so I get a fairly close position
but White has very decent chances with
the later F form yes understand yet the
quads he says he misses my daily
five-minute games every morning
yeah I know it's always good to have
some oops
what's that I did not expect that to
happen okay I have the fr now
interesting
yeah this is kind of I know what the
regularity of us was very nicely I was
very reliable in doing those but I
currently don't um don't want to do that
I'm not really so much into playing
those games anymore no wait wait wait
wait
um I think oh look a six year yeah that
that I should not miss
yeah the claim on the five-minute pool
that always did for the videos there are
some things that I didn't like all that
much after all those years the the thing
is I've the playing pool that it's very
strong but if you play the the game like
the eighteenth game against Eric LeBron
or Hagen with beat three the 100's game
it's kind of yeah and I didn't feel I
want to do that all the time and this is
actually a very interesting position
yeah we have I have extensive enough the
exchange but you see I've got all my
eight pawns and black has absolutely no
active play so um yeah I go look at five
and so on yeah it's true there's not so
much there's not so much analysis if I'm
doing a stream like that in a tournament
that's not that's not possible but I'm
not going to do those exclusively but
also do other content so it's a matter
of giving giving it a bit of time and I
need to experiment with formats and I
also think of doing the art the art the
symbol I wanted to say now I'm trying to
get to the pawn yeah we should appear
here here here and I don't see what you
can do against that
I don't think it can do much against
that I've got everything controlled
maybe see for some sort of break break
through it okay so he gives me the pawn
give me gimme gimme
we're checking f7 I can easily be
overlooked it just look at song back in
I don't want to repeat this is close to
a repetition but I forgot to do that I
could do a head to could have done that
before I'm not going to sing yeah you
don't tempt me into that after saying
give me give me mr. Ryan come on let's
go Dutch
mr. Ryan
maybe Knight takes d4 now is actually
strong hmm
he's playing as well mr. Orion I could
have taken only three actually
immediately mm-hmm now I didn't analyze
any other 0 games that didn't quite work
out
I can grab on f2 well I don't know d5 is
hanging which is kind of irritating it
really is this is however however a fork
so it's Sarah countercheck I not see it
okay so rook evade pin and win and
threatening rook takes f3 can cannot
hurt wins Queen okay so second place I'm
right after Eve on TV oh yeah those two
close to the lead yeah I'm I'm thinking
of different formats doing doing those
live I also think gaming game analysis
like I did for for Tata Steel things
like that can also be done quite nicely
in the life form it so I got this main
line here of the dutch against a gay
pianist okay this is a really really
sharp line it goes back interesting
[Music]
that's probably a bit too early on there
for me
this is getting interesting
okay so if I take white will probably
take with the e pawn that that I don't
want to have so I'm going to in age five
takes only five that looks that leads to
a very funny position yeah so I don't
want to trade but maybe I have to I
can't do this maybe Age 3 F 4 this is a
real kind of variation for hackers but
it looks extremely dangerous to be
honest pawn takes Bishop takes f3 I take
on g3 i William what's what's happening
here
pawn takes Bishop takes Queen moves f3
should also win for black and I'm
threatening our three to win Amir live I
don't know
so ich over
young maybe there's a question there's a
question that I could do man it's true
do game game analysis that's true yeah
you can actually do much more you can
actually do much more with the Nietzsche
studies then you can do with there with
some other software I am and that that's
simply not that that you cannot hold us
wish wish and over yeah that variation
is very dangerous
really this is it is extremely extremely
[Music]
yeah well what how to call it so but god
oh yeah it works yeah white is getting
blown off the board but if it doesn't
work oh so I have taken the Lydia but a
noscope he is a good player and Felicia
we played 93 okay iris kind of 6 cm and
we transpose which will begin a game
really what do we move
pratik here and play Bishop c5 isn't
that good okay
no white cannot castle here what goes on
here I just want to get rid of his good
a good piece them I'm threatening now to
take only five and play Queen 24 which
is duly ignored
Captain Obvious as Larry Christensen
would say but you know it works quite
often okay it's too tempting
it's too tempting not to play three yes
to go back to see one that doesn't look
very nice
but it seems to be the only option yep
[Music]
okay Wow what's going on here
but chica will be c3 probably and then I
go back to d6 white is really really
badly organized other people on stream
um interesting no I have no obvious
candidate down but I have club mates and
so on there there are some fairly strong
people but they don't live in to my
place so that would be tricky to do yeah
I'm going to go here and then mate on g2
that was the idea and he prevented it
for the time being
okay so I'm taking this and now look f2
and made on g2 I guess yeah that's true
I did like it do a commentary once with
her with a friend of mine okay there was
a couple of years ago yeah so Jeff still
leading but Skopje is closed no I really
feel that's not really I think why were
you in the tournament we should not get
those challenges and we all know here
with the Scandinavian defense
hey piece of sheet hello
says I'm not I'm not saying a lot I'm
why not
okay so a very very normal looking
position
hmm I didn't really pay attention just
should have done
and age three age three is a very useful
move
[Music]
[Music]
oh I start smoking in 2011 there so some
years ago there are only a couple of
videos where still smoked there are some
with the e electronic electric whatever
cigarette but I did this for for roughly
a year and then I stopped Italian no not
really going for Grand Master okay he
tries to go F for words you know I need
to get something going here and I want
to get some pressure okay my idea was to
check here
take care and now with all this I've
gained time and can go 95 that was my
idea but I'm not sure how good it really
is
I actually over looked at a three years
hanging mmm 56 not a bad move okay he
might take this but okay if I go here I
cannot move interesting
now I did not deserve this wasn't so
great it wasn't some rate it's their
delay I hope not
yeah don't like my position all that
much he has very nice peace placement I
was hoping that I could do something
with the pawn structure it didn't it
didn't really materialize at all
so I need to remit double Knight to f3
of course yeah I would like that but
cannot get there quickly he's six okay
Queen f3 no no I'm getting at least
little bit close I've got 20 seconds hey
why did nobody remind me guys then I got
no time
[Music]
I have absolutely no time no time
whatsoever
yeah three seconds I didn't pay
attention to the free end clock
absolutely no attention absolutely not
and now you're sitting there laughing
with me having three seconds okay I was
just speculating that it simply didn't
look at the clock yeah
minge the position was okay at some
point but I simply didn't look I just I
just didn't look okay so I have to get
some wins and Bullpups
that is a second place person here
now I'm quite happy with this blank is
fine here
I have equalized what that doesn't work
at all I don't need to do any fancy pre
moved
I just have this coming age three said
saving for the moment chick probably
let's this is best how it's the quick
what's the quickest Whitney actually I
can't this this and over
okay that was quick I was second place
hmm
okay I'm five points male that there was
super costly I'm losing that stupid game
poor anybody and okay full berserk mode
how many years of chess you got I'm
playing for roughly thirty years full
buzzer king mode in plain
what's a bishop going to do and taking
this piece not easy okay
if I take this nice check and this is
good but I thought maybe I have
something better
rook takes f6 is the threat so I'm
winning the Queen
look everyone mate is strong almost mate
okay I have to watch out a desert
there's some doing it with meters it's
helpful Queen g5 made now undercuts you
know if it takes Queen takes out that's
kicking is ke7 is hanging on for the
longest knowing that's the clock run
down okay I'm sorry
[Music]
funky effects I don't need no technolon
those dreams I have my the team
competitions with my club yeah we did
we're doing okay we've won the last two
matches in the league it was important
yeah except Y V V and n it's not playing
this is great yeah
simply spoiling my chances by wasting
one minute okay
it's what it is no I don't
I never message people for doing stuff
like that it's really pointless
well maybe it's connection what's the
thing you know I don't know oh yeah okay
so I'm six points behind and probably
cannot catch up
well it's copy you won all these games
that's good stuff playing Adriano again
it said the guy I lost on time against I
think yes I disliked I always forget it
this is something that really annoys me
it's not really great and I keep
forgetting this stuff no night 64
whatever this is really weird
this okay okay I just develop I just
develop stuff
maybe not the objectively best
continuation but I I just I just want to
play quick that looks quite comfortable
actually uh-huh even trades us hmm I
think I mean I know Led Zeppelin but
rambling didn't didn't really register
at the moment the title
okay I want to book the King on to e6 so
preparing that rambling oh oh it also
doesn't ring a bell
so g5 would be good to get get on the
board
oh he actually allows it just like that
it's very nice
you know you're not going to play before
just like that that's not going to
happen this would be fantastic
I'm trying that you were probably
probably prevented okay now I have the I
have the a phone okay is there anything
that I can do to punishing immediately
and maybe not
[Music]
the only thing that is potentially
worrying is rook trades this is if he
has I'm sorry if the rooks are kept on
the board that's what I'm trying to say
I can take F form not sure
I'll push him back here okay I'm taking
the pawn it's not such a clear decision
yeah probably local bishop takes e5 if I
play the ad I have to check the time
again I try to again yeah win on
position instead of just playing some
moves and you know playing too much for
quality instead of speed
okay after one rook is traded the
position should be really nice
[Music]
okay so it didn't manage to swim now all
of this but I did not I couldn't
actually look at the chat or anything
ahead so focused yeah okay so
third place and okay just two minutes
left
yeah well okay I think I'm doing okay at
the end here the Largo okay come on okay
this is not the kind of kind of line
where you can win quickly unfortunately
unfortunately not at all this is not
really good but I have to win like yeah
yeah ultralights beat I can't trust you
get the 95
position is actually not that bad I
think
okay that's nice it's nice stuff before
it's a good shot d3 and the thing is I'm
not really threatening to take them
Queen on the D foul is killing me yeah
okay I mean I tried to notify okay yeah
I tried to get in something super
quickly and it fired it backfired but
that was the only only possible chance
to get get to get to the first places
but he did a good job that I defended as
well so I got to God third and that guy
that I completely crushed won the
tournament that's funny
okay so I'm going to play some some
challenges yeah okay any any bullets
kind of challenge would be okay yeah it
was a bit too bizarre
but now I had to drive this is what I
usually do yeah okay so let's see what's
going on here I took on c6 early on
after a six it's kind of what year what
you have to do okay so I'm going to win
a bit of space and then see what to do
about this pawn structure it is not easy
from black to manage this pawn structure
if you place the deep hole
yeah those two will be very weak yeah
good night to bavarian swiss who is
leaving yeah it is it is late of course
b3 it's not a good idea
test to me yeah be three nights here be
393 my queen was lost
so no b3 for me okay okay so he has
captured this is a nice position in
strategic game okay I wonder where this
night is actually headed a 6th and c7
and then it doesn't do all that much ok
so he won't play d6 I think it will very
likely play f6 at some point it seems
the only way to free this pollution it
doesn't do that somehow ok I rook t1 was
actually stronger but ok this is not too
bad now those weaknesses here especially
Knight to d6 it's very tough to to deal
with and actually there are some rookie
3 would immediately threatened Knight f6
with attacking ideas here swing the rook
over Queen h6 this kind of thing it's
going to be difficult really even the
immediate Knight f6 could work but ok I
can do this ok and now I can play
another 6
that should work for sure check here and
that's me okay thanks for the game shoes
okay wow that's a super long list that's
killing killing the whole list yeah okay
so I'm just going to going from top to
bottom this is a bullet game actually I
only saw that now okay
try and try to get something going here
quickly and it looks dangerous you
cannot take it
t6 is made in two moves but the six is
the fairly awkward thread anyway
and mr. made in one that possible I also
did not pay attention to this which is a
bit awkward
[Music]
not good it's really tough to play
bullet all of a sudden he has to take it
okay
that's made make this made it's made
okay so thanks for the game janessa no
janessa is the next game I'm sorry okay
so okay okay let's go
I feel that Jake yeah really really
really really often people take won c-6
yeah this is my line against this and it
is sometimes a bit risky but what can
you do if you play a main lines I mean
which is of course not bad and play main
lines against the exchange the roof it's
really tough to get something
interesting going and this is at least
interesting so he suffers from that pin
that's a pretty annoying pin Bishop h5
looks funny I still do it
so I'm pinning in me and it's not so
easy to break that yeah this one okay
this is the only way to do it
technically so what's going on here yeah
I can take and be okay interesting as
it's got a question about my students
worked what successes they had I'm
mostly teaching adults so there there is
not like if you if you have an adult
student that has let's say 2000 or so
it's not easy to yeah to get an
improvement to let's say two thousand
two hundred over short time span I had a
couple who improved them like 100 points
something like that in that in that area
I only have one yeah junior student and
that work very nicely she improved
roughly three hundred points and one and
a half year so I'm trying to do
something here with my night against his
against his against his bishop okay so
he's giving me a pawn or she could be a
she giving me this pawn my favorite
current player I'm difficult it's not
something like I'm not rooting for
somebody I'm very very yeah
enthusiastically yeah I really don't I
think I like many of the author of the
top players from playing started like
Aronian very much it's also very nice
person I think it from what comes across
in interviews and then things
and chess wise I really am deeply
impressed what what Carlton is able to
do brilliant I mean it's it's extremely
it's extremely impressive in those quick
time controls sir it's also impressive
in in others but what do you what is
sometimes does in blitz chess and and
and and rapid justice is really
remarkable Jim this is this this sick
move to keep the pawn hey maybe I didn't
see any other solution to keep the ball
it really looks sick didn't spot that at
all
[Music]
this looks extremely weird mostly haha
no please don't let me lose this sick
game I was and now a rupee fire come on
this is sick amazing yeah yeah cousin
also one very clearly against Andrew
tang and bullet but that didn't surprise
me it's just a matter of playing
strength
I mean being quick as one thing but it's
it's a big difference
I just got killed by making very stupid
moves at the end but good game hereby
janessa well okay what did I do that was
very silly what I did and get I'm not
getting this writing up somehow by
losing pretty stupid games I'm sorry I'm
playing very stupid Mouse lips v6
instead of b5 that's sick again a mouse
lip and it's like you're losing
immediately it's a problem Wow what am I
doing here with my mouse
pretty weird the mouse problems okay
look f-five take is seven
so that looks pretty bad okay now I have
got the check I was thinking I should
win stuff I don't win stuff
huh
[Music]
it looks funny like I should have
something but I don't see it
[Music]
I can take here okay we could play this
but it's not winning or anything
it's got f6 against that but him I mean
he cannot see everything
have six threatening made and I have to
play g6 and there's probably some win
there for what okay he didn't say
look III 24 okay one isn't that that
convince a actually so okay let's keep
that pin on
[Music]
so I'm getting one pawn back Wow
these these are the kind of moves that
always send me into some sort of I feel
like really that is possible even
opening this up but he's fearless
and before didn't so here rook takes a
four on the cards
Nath's got Queenie 626
in c1
that isn't easy for what yeah but you
will probably still defend it somehow
check on each one this is what g3 DM Y
g3 was irritating I really felt that can
never work
probably and that wasn't so great my ID
3 no defense my catching with the night
I'm playing stupidly really stupid stuff
ok while I was more than lucky more than
lucky
yeah ok so let's go now 5 plus 3 is too
long that's really too long make do it
like those two add up to 5 at the mix
like 3 plus 2 something like that the
Lord Kinbote our kimochi I don't know
hmm maybe I can do that even here okay
so my idea is that I'm able to attack
the pawn multiple times here with Bishop
g7 and later 97 possibly 2f what's long
no rook e1 I was thinking first long
hair so I go crazy
yeah lots of stuff on there porn and he
did not defend it looking here and here
again
that's one key idea of the other con set
you check that fixed upon Center
sometimes it's fixed okay here in
excellent shape
yeah he gave me c3 I was really kind of
him it already was very problematic
after winning the D pawn you're probably
not don't have many chances to fight
yeah and Lord Kinbote to resign thanks
for the game let's go echo knight need
to go with another year for I should
maybe mix it up a little bit more play
more life form recently while working on
my repertoire for bass
let's get this Oh dad three plus two
years yeah three plus two is actually my
favorite time control in blitz
unfortunately you don't get to get this
so often don't get opponents for this so
often online yeah f7 how is he covering
f7 okay Quinn check every three no I
can't have to have to take first okay I
put this on that critical diagonal that
cannot be too bad it's the Cambridge
Springs and good response to d4 and well
okay it's just once a variation of the
Queens gambit and you cannot build a
repertoire based on the Cambridge
Springs I mean it can be this part of
your repertoire but you're not going to
get it too often here yes it's it's
easier to use an engine in three plus
two but I mean people if they want they
can cheat in one zero bullet so you just
can't bend bend the cheaters and I mean
up to this point you just have to assume
that they don't cheat em okay Queen f6 f
3m
the 1.e4 repertoire I don't think I'm
doing many concessions I mean the only
thing that I do with that
efore repertoire I'm basically saying
okay I'm not going to play a super
complicated lines and mostly go for for
quite simple solutions I think this is
just readily small concession it is
difficult to build up an e4 based
repertoire or any sort of repertoire
where you have this idea that you need
to play and no super aggressive whatever
this is going to be tough away sim will
be very time-consuming
so I'm saying in most of my lines just
get the ball rolling and play something
let's say normal okay this is actually
well defended by echo night the position
was pretty terrible and he is still
paying on
okay I'm taking here a new 94 for
possible Knight f5 the black queen is
not really having going right into it
what's not easy to find it with spot
down
yeah thanks for the game echo night so
let's go here
chip shot going 1.e4 again I could mix
it up with D for a little bit okay 95 I
guess
huh
that looks a bit strange to be honest
okay I cannot resist hey going for for
immediate punishment
so you're saying your favorite
repertoires were the ones where they
often went for aggressive sacrificial
lines in the main line and so you're
saying you like the wrapper to us that
don't work off yeah
there is no easy sacrificial lines in
the main line the student doesn't exist
they're authors that make you believe
you can play sacrificial great lines but
they're all rubbish which is where it is
every single early gambit is rubbish
okay so Queen age five
yeah play something against f4 and you
know II five I'm not a lot of hand of
the frogs gambit I don't think it sound
really okay so I tried to get to look
here to have three or he defended this
quite quite well let's try you know you
also get attacking positions when we
play normal lines that are not
sacrificial and unsound because if you
play we are less strong players they
will simply play so badly that you get
attacking positions with with norman
openings as well black is defending this
fantastically well after this very weird
opening ok i go a default for trying to
go be five but it looks a little bit
iffy here everything for me
I don't know against f4 I usually
recommend to just play d5 an interesting
line is actually have four d6
it's a funny line I've made a video by
the way if you want to check it out
drunk annoy and made a video on my
channel some like in early 2016
I think about battling all the main
lines and the bird was I was one of them
okay now I'm threatening Bishop f7 Queen
g6
and Queen g6 immediately EXO is also a
threat
d5 that's a good news okay rook e1 there
are a couple of funny attacking
possibilities here yes I made a video on
all those sidelines
[Music]
I can't believe how how is defending all
this playing the only moves to the whole
time yeah okay in a split second and
this is also King AJ I mean King a jade
is the only move
what takes what takes you so long it's
just totally lost I mean he defended
everything like perfectly after playing
the opening like no words okay it's it's
kind of strange sometimes
anyway let's play next opponent a little
bit mate Ted weird okay so here I'm
going to go oh okay
I'm not going to go default I was
thinking black would take with the Queen
on c6 but the mermaid actually decided
to to not do that okay so here and gain
going for this pawn b3 Bishop e3
yes that's very new so ish but with
colors reversed nimzo-indian themes
black has a really funky position like
in for indium zu Indian with Bishop on
b7 so I want the pawn and this is a
really great position if the knight on
c5 is one of the best pieces you can
imagine I came I'm not going to get mad
at him I could have played Queen g7
actually and it's just funny back and I
just ignore this I can take it
okay it's kind of silly not to take it
and it's just just a piece and now Queen
d4 and then Knight takes c6 something
like that knight c6 I get made it almost
made it on h2 let's stop it
I had queen ad8 actually take everything
and then night have seven fdn like you
know I can take Queen takes Queen d8
made when I was threatening Queen d8 why
the news o is hardly seen at the very
top level I don't think it's really that
that bad but the main thing is then why
it is often avoiding it with the Catalan
on with allowing a Queen's Indian or a
Queen's Gambit the nihms o is just so
extremely extremely well respected and
people tend to avoid it when they avoid
it it usually means they go for for for
fight and yeah I want to complicate it
game with with full with a full board
full blood of pieces so we have them
accelerated to Dragon him this move
orders I think slightly inaccurate what
why did you but I remember that this was
actually more complicated than it
usually then it looks at first so I
think you take it you know what is what
wha thank you keep with the bishop
at first this looks like complete
nonsense for white but this is not so
easy because white has very active
pieces a through you sometimes you also
see the BOGO Indian the opening that I
had suggested in my repertoire book
there was a recent game with the BOGO
right what was that
Misha Allen actually played the BOGO in
the German Bundesliga it was a draw I
did
ah not easy it's not so easy maybe here
and try to just neck snap this off yeah
it's an interesting point in the chat
yeah that in 2018 it's the first time
that you know maybe take the night that
they're actually people with who are
over the age of 18 so they could let's
say vote in most countries that are born
in the 2000 it's actually true this is
flying this really well i blundered this
I just blundered upon it's not so
terrible because I can have counterplay
against all these big points
yeah I actually sometimes if you think
about this sometimes feel or world when
I see let's say people compete in sport
events not just chess but also in chat
it's not it's kind of obvious that you
can be very strong when you're like 15
or 14 or so even younger but even in
some physical sports where you have
people born in the 2000s and actually
competing like on the highest level that
is always somewhat yeah somewhat
remarkable off somewhat to take no off
okay so he just blocks everything it's
really not easy to get anything look on
rope yeah it's probably just equal right
maybe I can get two beasts to to the b3
porn if he goes on this pond I can push
the Jeep on no reason to give it up okay
for 20 seconds this is the worst part
oops
check me anyway ah yeah great great
chess played the rook on the F pawn on
the F file okay okay
I'm really planning badly well okay I
mean really not good yeah too slow and
and imprecise okay
my rating gets down this is crazy I
should be 2600 or so on that side but it
seems tough compared to what others have
okay that's what's happening after c6
Wow there are so many different lines
Bishop c4 I can't remember
no there's nothing in the tea it's just
it's it's basically fruit based yeah I
think I'm I miss played this a little
bit him move all I was wrong somehow
okay hmm pretty awkward
after six I have to play h3 yes yeah h3
I forgot this i forgot my own liner that
I just studied recently here I have to
play after play h3 I have simply forgot
it I have simply forgotten it so I have
to hurry up that will be some tricky
game again with the time situation there
at h3 is the strongest move there
Ziggler says that that 95 school spell
might be but I looked at and look at the
other law and it was really good
yeah of course I could play my my usual
openings and not try out what I'm
currently studying but that that feels a
bit lame I mean I can I can play neither
a3 g3 every game and use no time at all
but I'd like to I like to try out some
new things c4 and this is not playing
perfectly should 5 fields dangerous
really feels dangerous for black
they cannot take the pawn I have queen
g2 at the end okay six or whatever I
don't know
Queenie age it's got everything under
control here
I don't know we have seven hangs you
know okay yeah I take f7 now again so
pawn was sort let's go on just going
from top to top to bottom
what is the pawn with sort of Jim he
should play him in the first place
no he does okay so it's gone five
I have to admit it's very tempting it's
not totally terrible if it's not totally
terrible
you can place stuff like this yeah play
chess is currently this is really not I
don't like that at all it's really not
good yeah in porn we thought actually
resigned yeah that was an early knockout
with a good finish form it's called
Mario Leo okay let's go D for them did
not meant to paint paint that so this is
what I usually play that thing yeah good
night - doing a rustle you have to get
up at 7:00 a.m. okay that is early
I have 8:30 at least
okay I went to look t1 this is quite a
good position for the work it makes it
difficult for black to actually play the
free moves that is usually after okay
let's do it I'm not quite sure if I want
to go see five here push up g3 and B
form
it's not so bad him
why Queen c2 sir earlier mites well it's
a normal line actually it's a fairly
respectable side line in the Slav so we
have a very nice space advantage and
black has a hard time to ever play e5
it's the thing so going to centralize
this well I can't take it I was on that
square quite a lot actually move f4
forever that would have been rest you
but actually why kill your own your own
bishop
so ef4 is important they're preventing
e5 forever basically and now I can play
against those pawns g5 is actually
something that I should have paid more
attention to create yeah maybe Queenie
too
yeah point rate would essentially be
game over yeah I'm looking at this
threatening rook on the seventh it looks
pretty pretty okay
maybe he has stuff like that and then
regret for I shouldn't have played
before that was a stupid move let's
cover this a little bit at least so that
it cannot take on before and somehow
make this position more messy yeah
now that was absolutely not well played
but I have to solve problems and that
shouldn't be the case I was like
completely winning position without any
counter play at all still I'm not so
sure how it is going to defense it seeks
to be honest I don't see a good move
take here next
I'm taking absolutely everything 3d yeah
thanks for thanks to all the new
followers I can dream of queen h7 yeah
thanks for the game Mario Leo chess
dilettante is the next one you're going
to get my rating back to 2000 Rodino 96
actually to castle because I'd like to
get in c3 and typhoid possible and often
you surprisingly often you manage to get
the hell this is just a nice position
for white getting this big sentient I
don't know black black sock how to play
is really limited but to prevent any
Bishop g4 from happening
no that looks comfortable for white I
don't know where to put this so here b5
maybe coming
no it looks comfortable p5 I have a
three
maybe night a five-night zero okay
not sure what is up to t5
mmm that looks a little bit odd
okay lotta work to do later on we
already had almost 1 a.m. now I'm not
going to do any work after the stream
I'm going to play one or two more games
I'm going to finish at 1 a.m. roughly
our time no let's not blunder into night
b3 yeah I have some some work to do
tomorrow but I've got some lessons
tomorrow but also going to continue to
work on the e4 repertoire because I want
to get it again it get it finished as
soon as possible goes back knight on b7
looks really wrong it's a really weird
looking piece and thought it would still
play Knight c4 would have been
technically a bit more complicated and
maybe not great but the knight on b7
looks strange Knights it's it's very
unusual for Knights to be good on
vehicle positions so knight on b7 g 7b7
i don't think there's much chess a
notation where you reach the knight on
b7 is a beast or something he probably
won't won't hear that
the big issue for black is said if he
pushes d5e five is good it opposes e5d
five is good so he has a hard time to do
something to do something good in the
center and I can just double on the C
file I've got more space and at some
point D five will be strong
yeah Blackie I mean it's three plus two
but she Hey okay so I am get design
after all right this step be 64 that
would be something that is good for my
body result yeah it's going to be very
difficult for black this position 97
here like 97 I wanted to go Knight c5
chapter tough to defend with no space
okay thanks for the game just did it on
some going with oscillations and let's
go c4 let's mix it a little bit so this
is a five-minute game so this will
probably be the final game for for the
stream in English here let's see what
oscillations is up to Bishop before
Bishop c5 yeah these are the the main
moves yeah white basic strategic idea
with a setup like this is that the
center is going to be closed because it
has a grip on that Square and d5 and
that makes it easier for white to play
on the flanks before f4 those kind of
things and in this case I'm going to
prepare a for I play this so then I have
King age 2 if Bishop c5 happens
okay so f4 immediately I mean you see he
prepared f5 I think it's so feels like I
should do it
and yeah this is actually in the c-4
repertoire that I did I released some
time ago I don't have c4 e for positions
that often in that repertoire but
against this particular move order I do
recommend to go with you form it is
actually I'm very often quite good to
play C 4 and E form just that in net in
my repertoire I'm not recommending that
all of the time again not for quality
reasons one reason why I didn't go for
c4 and e4 that much in my repertoire was
that this kind of setup has been covered
a lot actually in in chess books and
other publications for example Marine
the Romanian Grand Master had
recommended that in his English books
and I did not want to suggest the same
lines I mean I think an author should
try to yeah if possible present
something that it's not covered to death
in chess literature or other content
okay so I'm going for an attack though
see 44 lines are actually quite
aggressive sometimes on the kingside him
well so he allows me to push f6
not sure about this that's actually
remarkable you're right
when I point see people says there's a
new book coming up called endgame
virtuoso Magnus Carlsen yeah there was
not yet a book about consoles and games
why why did nobody write this Hey
yeah would have been indeed a worthy
subject the automatic response is to
take with the bishop I actually should
do that it's temple and then I have a
three year
I completely yes a three I needed to
play 95 first Jim and and now and the
bishop is trapped no it is trapped so
Tillett is speaking subtext if I have
made some sense actually but strategy is
not important if you if you just win a
piece for nothing in particular
okay so how to do this h4 h5 maybe well
it's a piece I mean I don't need to rush
things here there's no there's no reason
not to take this okay and oscillations
resigns so if there is one if there is
any bullet challenge in there I would
take it but there isn't like one more
game one bullet challenge I would play
one bullet game to finish the stream am
I out of team I'm not out of team anyway
one bullet challenge maybe for a final
game enough Dan yeah okay this counts as
bullet so let's go
it's 2-0 but technically it's bullet so
let's do it and now it's not moving
let's take the center d5 is unusual
it's a take the center no maybe I can
actually win this pawn on d5 yeah
huh it covers it
he covers it okay to have this self I
have this I'm wondering
[Music]
what's going on hey it's a bit strange
let's go back in if six mmm
ah okay I didn't see that sometimes
really don't don't see the chat iam not
it's not meant in any unfriendly way if
I if I look at the board
I simply don't register what is on the
chat screen so trying to win see for
difficult to keep and actually find out
hang so let's do this and try to use
this
yeah one cannot take none I take the
three the chick I was spycheck coming
with c5 and no no challenge is anyway
I'm going to stop after this game so I'm
winning the Queen okay so thanks for the
game I've done yeah yeah I've been on
for two hours yes I originally had
planned so yeah thanks a lot for
watching I'm very happy with the new
account got many many viewers in the
stream yeah thanks a lot for watching
I'll be on next week same time and 11:00
p.m. Central European Time I'm not quite
sure I will also do other content so it
could be some something else I also want
to yeah the drunken law and the [ __ ]
says see you on Wednesday I always have
a Wednesday show on chest 24 not only
chess but it's also you have me
streaming playing chess against viewers
chatting and I will have an announcement
on my youtube channel about that as
usual it would be Wednesday at 7 p.m.
Central European Time and also an
additional show that I'm going to have
will be on Sunday Sunday evening at 9
p.m. Central European Time that would be
actually on the ICC's internal Chess
Club YouTube channel about a couple of
rounds of tarsiers I'm going to do some
fantasy highlights for the ICC on Sunday
evening there will also be the art show
on leeches in the meter I don't know
that they are not like scheduled yet I
will do those when I just have some time
and I feel sick about I don't want to do
books anymore whatever and I'll play
some some games and stream thanks
for watching I'll be back soon enough
bye-bye